ich bin so desperate diese Punkte zu
bekommen dieses scheiß Flo muss jetzt
funktionieren ich habe zwar kein
angelquipment aber jetzt komme ich doch
noch dazu
[Musik]
mückenfie jetzt geht es in Nacht Nummer
6 bedeutet die vorletzte Nacht
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden
kämpft ein man
mit sie gegensten ums Überleben ich bin
wieder da der erste Versuch endete für
den Outdoor Neuling schnell mir ehrlich
übel Leid und H waren ihm dadurch sicher
doch jetzt ist er zurück an dem Ort an
dem alles beganer gutm keine kamerams
jetzt geht ab kein Kontakt
zur kmen zu Dave se Vers wild
zweitversuch die heutige Folge wird euch
präsentiert von Monopoly go was
hoffentlich nicht nur in mir absolute
Kindheitserinnerung hochholt und mit
Monopoly go habt ihr ab sofort euer
Lieblingsspiel aus der Kindheit immer in
der Hosentasche dabei das Spiel kommt
mit dem originalen look and feelel allen
bekannten Straßen und Spielfiguren und
natürlich auch dem einzig warahren
monopolyann es an sich die perfekte
Symbiose aus altem nostalgischem
Spielbrett und modernem mobile game zum
einen gibt es die Klassiker rund um
Straßen kaufen ereignisfelder und
natürlich das Gefängnis dazu kommen aber
auch neue zeitlich limitierte Modi wie
z.B Corp Events ab Level 5 und
interaktive Features wenn man z.B auf
einen der vier Bahnhöfe kommt denn genau
dann habt ihr die Möglichkeit so richtig
abzukassieren entweder ihr bekommt die
Möglichkeit Gebäude anderer Spieler
anzugreifen oder einen Überfall auf sie
zu starten je mehr ihr erspielt desto
schneller könnt ihr eure Gebäude
ausbauen und Level um Level aufsteigen
ladet euch also jetzt komplett kostenlos
Monopoly Go über diesen QR Code oder den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
herunter und holt euch nostalgiepur fürs
SM vielen Dank an Monopoly go fürs
möglich machen der letzten Folge meines
se ver 2
[Musik]
Versuchs Tag Nummer 7 ich habe so ewig
gepennt also wirklich
ewig und ich schlafe hier so gut drin
komplett an der frischen Luft aber meine
Nase ist immer noch dicht ich weiß auch
nicht ob das jemals wieder weggehen wird
jetzt stehen wir auf kümmern uns um die
let
Challenge und genießen den letzten
[Musik]
Tag es wä zu schön
gewesen bitte und soll ich euch was
sagen mich nervt es nicht mal mehr ich
habe komplett damit abgeschlossen das
hier ist der siebte Tag ich gehe kein
Risiko mehr ein dann habe ich es mir
bewiesen dann habe ich es allen anderen
bewiesen und dann ist das durch und dann
vor allem werde ich mir so krank Nudel
Burger und die ganze andere Scheiße
reinhauen auf die ich die letzten Tage
verzichtet habe ich kann es euch jetzt
nicht zeigen aber meine Hose ist am
Anfang der 7 Tage ohne Gürtel nicht
gerutscht und jetzt habe ich
zentimeterweise Platz zwischen meinem
Bauch und der Hose aber nach wie vor
weil ich weiß dass ich jetzt nicht an
Essen komme denke ich fast gar nicht
drüber nach und ich habe quasi keinen
Hunger ich merke dass ich unheimlich
wenig Kraft habe aber das war jetzt eine
schöne Exkursion
aber jetzt reicht sieht man eigentlich
dass ich dünner geworden
bin me Bad ist
länger aber ich weiß nicht ob man sieht
dass ich dünner bin ich fühle mich auf
jeden Fall wie vor d Jahren wie so eine
richtig schmale Nudel Tag Nummer 7 der
Tag ist schon halb vorbei die ganze Zeit
weitergepennt ich warte auf das Ende bau
dir ein Denkmal deine aufgabeel so viele
Steine wie möglich aufeinander gemessen
wird ab dem ersten selbstgesetzten Stein
die Höhe ist dabei das zu messende
Kriterium der Stapel muss eigenständig
eine Minute lang stehen dokumentiere das
Maß auf Kamera du hast Zeit bis die
Sonne untergeht aber stützen oder das
aneinanderkleben mit Harz ist nicht
erlaubt let's
go es ist eintönig ja aber es geht mir
noch nicht so richtig auf den Sack ist
nicht so dass mir der Geschmack jetzt
wirklich zum Hals raushängt oder so zum
Abschluss laufe ich noch mal ganz nach
vorne an die
Landzunge damit das Denkmal auch in
besten möglicher Position ganz vorne in
voller Pracht erstrahlen
kann jetzt kann ich euch übrigens auch
mal zeigen was ich mit der Hose gerade
eben
meinte so viel Platz ist hier und ich
habe die gekauft so dass sie mir perfekt
gepasst hat und klar die dehnt sich dann
über 1 Z D Tage weil man sie viel trägt
aber so viel hat die sich garantiert
nicht gedehnt
ich darf ja nicht
stützen
ich bin schon zu
schief steht noch ziemlich
stabil
alter Junge das läuft ja wie am
Schnürchen hier so um gar nichts zu
verschwenden messe ich jetzt den einfach
schon mal durch und lass den eine Minute
stehen 1 m und 1 cm
hier der bleibt jetzt eine Minute
stehen Alter schaut mal was ich für ein
perfekten Stein gefunden
habe oh nein dumm dumm dumm
[Musik]
dumm
Mann
diger okay ich habe einen neuen Plan ich
ma eine double Base und dann baue ich
immer parallel
hoch so war ja ngendwo die Rede von das
muss darf nur ein Stein in der Basis
sein ne soll wir ein Denkmal bauen aha
jetzt haben wir hier die Stabilität die
wir brauchen
messen stehen
lassen
1,1 eine Minute stehen
lassen 1,1 log
in
bitte ein
23 stehen
lassen ich bleib mal lieber hier drin
stehen damit ihr seht dass die timelapse
auch wirklich eine Minute
ist so der nächste
131 stehen
[Musik]
lassen so
136 stehen
lassen
so
[Musik]
wird wackelig
156 noch 30 cm bis auf meinen
Kopf da muss jetzt aber auf jeden Fall
noch irgendwas drauf hier das ist die
Spitze der Verdammnis die kommt da jetzt
oben
drauf
[Applaus]
das war's den nehmen wir ich wollte
immer mehr immer mehr ich habe
glücklicherweise immer zwischendrin
gestoppt aber der war stabil der hat
[Musik]
gepasst das war offiziell die letzte
Challenge von meinem zweitversuch 7 ver
wild und jetzt genieße ich diese
Aussicht und freue mich wenn hier da
vorne morgen früh dieses kleine Boot
angetuckert
kommt und ich hier rauskomme
ah was für ein Segen die Tage
verschwimmen komplett ich weiß gar nicht
mehr wann was passiert ist ich habe es
genossen ich habe es gehasst ich habe
was gelernt ich freue mich aber jetzt
auch einfach wieder auf zu Hause keinen
Bock mehr aber ich hab es geschafft
verdammte scheiße ich habe es geschafft
nach dieser miserablen Leistung in
Staffel 1 war das jetzt auch wirklich
das Mindeste was ich tun konnte für mich
für mein eigenes Ego und für euch die
von mir nur einen halben Tag in Staffel
1 bekommen
haben hier ist nichts hier ist gar
nichts
hallo ich werde verrückt
langsam verrückt
Tag 7 neigt sich dem Ende es hat
funktioniert ich habe es durchgezogen
ich habe mein Setup schon fertig gemacht
für die letzte Nacht ich werde früh
abgeholt muss das alles noch
zusammenräumen mein Lagerplatz fürs Holz
perfekt funktioniert meine Feuerstelle
Feuer hinbekommen challenges gemacht und
einfach keine Kraft mehr ich freue mich
einfach auf die Zivilisation und ich
lass den Abend wie auch die letzten Tage
schon einfach in der Hängematte
ausklingen ich kann nicht mehr und ich
will nicht mehr aber ich bin unheimlich
happy die letzte Nacht ich liege und
genieße in wenigen Stunden werde ich
abgeholt und ich muss mich wirklich bei
meinem Schelter bedanken es hat mir
beste Dienste
erwiesen es ist unglaublich es kommt so
ein Grinsen über mein Gesicht wenn ich
daran denke dass es jetzt wirklich
vorbei ist gute gute Nacht an ihr
schlaft gar nicht gute Nacht an mich die
letzte
Nacht
geil es ist
soweit Mücke scheißegal Camp abbauen
zusammenräumen abholen lassen und ab
nach hause ja
alles ist in dichten Nebel
gehüllt Tag 8 ich schmeiß die scheiße
jetzt hier so zusammen Alter dryback auf
alles rein und
[Musik]
fertig meint ihr ich kann die Blombe
jetzt
aufmachen dann kann ich viel besser
packen hier auch noch die genau gleiche
Nummer
Alter ich höre das Boot ich höre das
Boot hört ihr das es ist soweit ich
werde abgeholt ich schmeiß die schei
jetzt einfach den
[Musik]
dryback oh mein Gott ich habe keine Lust
auch nur eine Sekunde zu verlieren ich
glaube real Talk das Boot ist schon
da das war's mach's gut 7 Verss wild
Staffel 1.1 Dave Edition meine Hose
rutscht der dryback ist komplett
voll das ist
over das ist
over
Alter
Michael
Alter was läuft Alter alles frisch oder
was Scheiße komm Abfahrt Alter kein Bock
mehr kein Bock
mehr so nach Hause ab nach Hause ab nach
hause warte
mal
jawoh
Alter was für eine
Tour ein letztes Mal Sumpf
Insel Michael am
Boot jetzt geht's durch den Nebel ab
nach hause Richtung Zahnbürste Dusche
Essen
Alter geil
Alter
adios auf nimmer
wiedersehen
Alter
ich hab es gemacht s Vers wild Staffel
1.1 Dave Edition 7 Tage sieben Nächte
wir haben es
geschafft
ja
rich das ist ja so geil
oh mann ey da kommen fast die tren sage
ich euch wie es ist das hat mich zwei
Jahre lang bedrückt dass ich da so eine
scheiß Leistung abgeliefert
habe aber ich habe es wieder gut
gemacht
vorbei kann ich aus meinem Kopf
streichen boah mein
Gott
100 m trennen mich von der
[Musik]
Zivilisation Alter ich sind wieder da oh
mein
Gott
[Musik]
Alter
endlich junge überhaupt kein Bock mehr
alter Tage alter ich bin so unheimlich
happy und ich habe so Bock auf Cola oder
irgendwas was mir so richtig so eine
kranke satisfaction gibt was mir nichts
geben konnte was da draußen war oh ich
habe gerade echt ein kleines Tränchen
verdrückt am Boot wie geht's dir oh ja
bestens ich bin schlapp Alter ich bin
richtig schlapp ich glaube ich habe das
die ganze Zeit nicht gemerkt aber ich
bin richtig schlapp Alter mein Mund ist
so trocken ich habe auch die letzten
zwei Tage viel weniger Wasser getrunken
weil ich keinen Bock mehr auf die Plörre
hatte du hast wirklich was so sewasser
getrunken was ja die ganze
Zeit und abgekocht aber es ging ich
merke das gar nicht mehr ne aber ich
glaube ich bin richtig wacklig auf dem
Bein ich habe mich die letzten Tage so
da dran gewöhnt aber jetzt wo ich hier
ankomme und mich das erste Mal wirklich
entspannen kann merke ich wie sehr mir
das in den Knochen und überall drin
hängt bis ins Mark ich bin
durch kann ich das Trinken
Niklas einfach frisches
Wasser
das
[Musik]
Alter 7 Uhr morgens mir wurde Essen
gekocht was für ein Traum
diger
mit Pesto könnt wirklich nichts geileres
vorstellen oh mein Gott iche gerade
schon Pesto so
gegessen komplette Geisteskranke
Geschmacksexplosion zieht sich alles so
zusammen weil me Mund das gar nicht mehr
gewohnt ist wovon hast du dich ernährt
Blaubeeren und diese Spitzen an den
Bäumen das ja und vor allem habe ich
mich eigentlich gar nicht ernähr ich
habe händeevoll gesammelt aber das ist
das ist ja
nichts aber ist mir auf jeden Fall klar
geworden in der Zeit genau das was ich
mache noch mehr noch
extremer noch viel
besser und vor allem auf sehr lange
unbestimmte Zeit machen will so Bo
Videos zu produzieren da seit 10 Jahren
und in den letzten drei Jahren so
geisteskrank intensiv dass viele Leute
um mich rum sagen dass es zu viel ist
aber mir ist klar geworden dass ich das
genaauo richtig finde und am liebsten
das noch mehr will meine Freundin hätte
sich so erhofft dass ich ein Gang
runterfahren will volle Kraft
voraus habe so Bock auf große Formate
und ich hab ein paar richtig gute Ideen
aber erstmal hast du Hunger erstmal das
ist
[Musik]
Sch